hello everybody i am back for another
video and this one we're going to start
actually talking about you know existing
databases and actually apply some of the
knowledge that we've hopefully learned
in some of the last few videos
so the first channel announcement i have
to quickly make is that i'm almost at
100 subscribers
which uh you know the second i get there
i can actually quit my job because it
means that i've actually become a
full-time influencer i'm pretty sure
that's how it works
but um yeah in the meantime until i get
that hundredth subscriber let's talk
about some of the pitfalls of relational
databases
a lot of people will use the term sql
and nosql and i don't particularly like
doing that because not all relational
databases use sql
nosql is a super broad term i prefer
non-relational databases but even within
non-relational databases there are graph
databases key value stores wide column
databases
and other options too
so keeping all of that in mind
i'm just going to use the terms
relational and non-relational for now
and this video is generally going to be
about why relational databases are not
always the answer and then in subsequent
videos i'll do more of a case study on
some of the other options that we have
to implement
okay let's talk about the pitfalls of
relational databases well for me to talk
about why something is bad i must first
talk about what it actually is
let's talk about the background so
relational databases are comprised of
tables that hold a bunch of rows of
structured data that means they're using
a predefined schema which means that all
of the columns have been predefined on
the table creation and until you do some
sort of alter table or use like an
optional field or something like that
the schema generally stays
constant which makes it a little bit
hard to adapt additionally the whole
point of this is that the rows of one
table can have relationships with rows
of another table if they share a common
key that key is generally known as a
foreign key and then finally there is a
built-in query optimizer that returns
results using the declarative sql
language what is a declarative language
it means that basically you're going to
type in the format or of the result of
the query that you want so basically
saying i want to select everything from
this table and provide me with this type
of information too and then this query
optimizer is going to say okay i know
the result that he wants let's go ahead
and now do that the most efficient way
possible using a combination of indexes
parallelism and a bunch of other things
under the hood so in this way relational
databases are a little bit of a black
box
the most popular relational databases
that you might have heard of are
probably mysql and postgresql
okay
here are some other implementation
details generally speaking they use b
trees we've spoken about b trees in the
first episode on this channel and if you
recall that means you're writing and
reading from disk additionally they
support transactions using two-phase
locking this is another thing we've
spoken about on the channel and then
finally all reads and writes go to disk
okay let's talk about actually scaling a
relational database so traditionally
most people scaled their relational
database vertically what that means is
instead of actually just using more
nodes to put the database on what they
went and did is just use a more powerful
machine this led to things like
mainframes now however everyone wants to
do cloud computing which means that we
have a bunch of generic computers
located in data centers which you can
rent out and use a certain amount of
compute units if we want so everyone
wants to scale horizontally that means
that we're just scaling on generic
hardware like i said
so as a result of that generally
speaking we have to end up sharding or
partitioning our sql tables
this is where things honestly start to
get challenging
okay so let's go into some problems with
charting
first i'm going to talk about the
problems with sharding on rights so
imagine that we have um you know a
single leader replication set up for
each shard
and i am going to be venmo and i want to
transfer a thousand dollars from putin
to trump that's actually a typo who are
on different partitions so here's what's
going to happen is i have those guys on
different partitions and then i'm going
to create this transaction and it's
going to say trump balance increased by
a thousand dollars putin balance uh
decreased by a thousand dollars
however what if it happened to be the
case that only one of those network
requests actually reached the proper
partition
trump say gains a thousand dollars but
putin never loses his and then me as
venmo i lose a thousand dollars because
i just messed up my transaction so in
order to do so we need to make sure the
operation either succeeds on both
partitions or fails on both but this is
over the network so we're no longer just
using a single computer level
transaction now what we're doing is
something called a distributed
transaction and i'll actually get into
how we might do this in a future video
but for now all i'm going to say is that
distributed transactions since they have
to get both of these nodes to agree on
doing something
is going to use a lot of network
resources and is going to be much slower
than just a single computer transaction
as a result writing to multiple
partitions at once in a transactional
way can be very slow
okay continuing with the problems of
sharding now let's look at what happens
when we want to do a read let's imagine
i'm using facebook messenger and i want
to see all of the chats that i'm in so
i'm jordan and my user id is one so
according to this many-to-many
relationship table which i'll just call
user chats i now see that as user one
i'm a member of chats with id one three
five and seven so you can see those two
partitions below where the chats are
located so the first partition holds
chat ids from one to four and the second
holds chat ids from five to eight as you
can see i'm going to actually have to
query both partitions to find
all of the chats i'm in and then
aggregate those results the fact that i
have to make multiple network calls is
again problematic why well because one
of them could fail and then i would have
an incomplete query or just in the more
general case the fact that i have to do
multiple of these queries means that
things are going to take longer network
requests are always
bad and you want to minimize them when
you can
okay so now that brings me to kind of
the relational philosophy because we'll
see how in many ways this can kind of
scale poorly
every single piece of data has only one
copy we want to normalize data not
denormalize it so that that way if we
make a change to one piece of data which
a bunch of other pieces of data
reference
that change is now going to be
propagated so that's kind of the idea of
reducing duplication
secondly each table has one preset
schema this allows you to kind of encode
data better and in addition to that it
just makes for simplifying things into
one easy to use table
thirdly we're going to fetch related
data via joins a join in a relational
database is basically saying okay i have
one thing let's call it um
i don't know a profile
think about like a linkedin profile i
have a linkedin profile and then all of
my job listings are going to be in a job
listing table and each job listing has a
user id which shows that it corresponds
to my profile because those are my
experiences you know it says like oh i
worked at amazon now i'm working at
google and now it's going to have the
user ids
of myself on there so joining is
basically saying take all of those rows
with a corresponding user id and fetch
them
so that's how you would uh you know
continue to kind of work into that idea
of reducing data duplication
finally we're going to hide concurrency
bugs and partial failures via
abstractions in this case transactions
okay why is this problematic
well for starters the second that
sharding gets involved
all of this data splitting becomes super
problematic we have to make a bunch of
network calls
both on reads and on right on rights for
distributed transactions and on reads in
order to basically go ahead and
aggregate results from a bunch of
partitions
additionally to actually just have
transactions on a single node requires
something like two two phase locking
which can be very slow because it means
that reads and writes can actually block
one another
finally the b trees that all of these
relational databases use because they've
been around for so long and basically
that's all that existed was b trees are
very slow for writing compared to some
in-memory buffer like an lstm tree
okay so what if we want to move away
from relational databases
there's this term nosql that you
probably have heard by now and generally
what that means is a non-relational
database
so in reality nosql databases aren't the
opposite of sql or anything it's really
just taking a database as we know it and
stripping down a bunch of these features
and abstractions that are part of a sql
database which is basically a black box
and once you strip down these features
it allows you to kind of increase
performance while only taking kind of
the features that you want
okay so what are some of the design
patterns of nosql
well most importantly objects are
generally going to be self-contained
documents what does that mean it means
there's more locality on disk everything
that is related in data is going to be
stored next to one another so you know
if we're looking at my linkedin profile
and i have all of these job experiences
instead of storing the job experiences
in their own table i would actually
store those experiences say in something
like a json document with my profile in
general so that would contain you know a
link to my profile image um a profile
description and generally everything is
going to be stored together this is good
because sequential reads on disk are
more efficient and as a result
everything is going to be sequential and
easier to read from and write to this
also makes things easier to shard i can
literally just split up the documents it
doesn't really matter which shard
they're on because at the end of the day
everything that that document is going
to need is already with it it's
self-contained
next it's schema-less this is really
good for applications like machine
learning or anytime you basically just
want to dump a ton of data into a
database without kind of worrying about
formatting it or putting it in a way
that it needs to fit into a given table
it's also really good for
maintainability because that means that
your data can adapt over time in the
event that you want to make changes to
your data without having to add things
like optional fields
and then finally
the main pitfall of all this is data
duplication let's say i'm using a nosql
database and i have a document for a
bunch of books in a library well in an
sql database or a relational database
what you might do is you know each
author would have an
object or a row in a table
and then if an author writes multiple
books each book can reference the same
author via an author id in a nosql
database i might have to repeat that
author information multiple times now
let's say this author is actually still
alive and decides to change their name
or something
now i'm going to have to go to every
single book written by that author and
change their name so this could
potentially take a lot of application
side code which is pretty unfortunate
in addition while i did say that most
nosql databases are self-contained
documents there are also no sql
databases that are graph databases and
these are really good for many to many
relationships which those document
databases are not very sufficient for
document databases are generally good
for when data isn't self-contained
documents and there's not too many
relations between the data however graph
databases represent things like social
networks really really well because it
allows you to put metadata with each
node and link between the nodes those
are also schema-less
okay so in conclusion for relational
databases
the real main benefit of relational
databases is that a lot of people have
experience with them and as a result
they're very intuitive and people
understand them well people know how to
do one-to-many relationships they know
how to do many-to-many relationships and
generally things make sense however the
second you get sharding involved and you
want to do some sort of horizontal
scaling things can go pretty poorly you
may have to use distributed transactions
and read joins can take a really really
long time across multiple partitions
additionally the fact that by nature
most of these relational databases use
transactions is bad because two-phase
locking can be very slow
furthermore e-trees are really slow for
writes compared to things like lstm
trees which go to memory
additionally the set schema makes the
database hard to maintain in the long
run in the event that your data is
evolving
and then finally generally speaking
these relational databases use single
leader replication because it's kind of
just more simple and as a result of that
it limits your right throughput so you
know for right throughput increases it
tends to be the case that you want to
use something like nosql
so as a result nosql databases have
gained a lot of popularity because they
relax a lot of these requirements used
by relational databases
even though this can definitely add some
complexity to your code you kind of have
to look at the specific requirements of
your application and decide what you
need and you don't need for example if
you're a bank and you want to make sure
that account balances are staying
consistent and synchronized you probably
do need transactions and a relational
database is still the way to go but for
a lot of things like messenger services
and social media apps the increased
right throughput and lack of need for
complete consistency by nosql is
actually a really good thing
okay furthermore this doesn't mean that
sql is infeasible like i just said in
that bank account example it's still
really useful
however even if you just have a read
heavy application
and highly related data relational
databases can still be good
um it's the case that just since
everyone's so familiar with them if you
can get away with using a relational
database you probably should because
it's just pretty simple to reason about
the data
additionally many companies really like
that kind of sql interface but want to
improve the underlying technology below
it and so there are things like volt db
and google spanner which have tried to
improve the scalability of the
relational model and some people are
calling that new sql and i'll talk about
that in a later video as well
another thing to note is there's no
database that is perfect for every
application it's only by breaking down
how each of them works that we can
decide which one to use in a given
situation
okay so i hope this makes sense why
relational databases have kind of
decreased in popularity a little bit but
overall they're still super common so at
the end of the day all we can really do
is understand what a relational database
is and then also look at some possible
other options like cassandra or
couchbase or anything along those lines
and see which is best for our
application if you're doing a systems
design interview being able to break
down why you picked a given database is
really huge and as a result i think the
next few videos are going to be really
important